[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you're not going to believe this one it
was the last week of senior year so
we're just getting crazy
we're about to graduate so we're at this
park having a big
keg party just middle of the day so then
is is high school this is high school
where i went to a catholic high school
we're in our uniform yeah we got like a
half day so we're like let's go to the
park we've got a keg we're out there
it's like
you know 100 of us drinking so my friend
packy
who was like a sophomore he wasn't
pakistani his name was like
like pakenstein jeff pakenstein or
something so we called him packy
and he shows up with my friend dirty
turk
[Laughter]
so he was this crazy kid who we let hang
around us he was way younger he was like
two feet tall
skinny as hell but he was he was he
would do anything he said like
go jump off that building go say a
racial slur in front of that guy
like a jackass it was like jack but he
was fearless
really shine for a little bit i think
his name is stevo
yeah and he's still doing pretty good in
and out of boarding school
like parents killed themselves in front
of him one of these kids you know just
seen it all
he was up for anything so where we he
goes
oh i got to get something oh there's a
house party it's a house party so we
jump on in my car at a convertible we
jump in my car we're going to this house
party
we're in our our uniforms and everything
and i'm trying it's rush hour now so i'm
trying to get into a
lane to merge off the highway and i go
hey man can i get in can i get in the
guy goes
nope gives me like a hard nope and i was
like [ __ ] this guy
so i get him behind him and i bump him
just for the hell of it
we're hammered you know it's you know
it's five o'clock with a [ __ ] face
i give him a little taparoo so that he's
like
so he's like in the mirror like what the
[ __ ] is going on here
and we're doing like you know blow me
hit a ponytail it was a whole thing
no offense
whatever you [ __ ] drunk boat dad
so so he's like [ __ ] you i'll kill you
whatever and then we're like oh this guy
wants to play so i tap him again now
he puts his car in park that would send
me over the edge that would make me so
god damn it
yeah like if you did it like you were
like
in the beginning we go what's wrong with
mark's brain i love that mark goes oh
this guy wants to play huh
so i tap them again what state is this
new orleans so he puts the car in park
he gets out so now we're like well i
guess this is on
you know but there's two of us i got
packy here back he'll [ __ ]
just lunge at him like a rat real quick
take out his knees i'll just
you know claw his neck so uh he gets out
and he walks past
me so i'm kind of like ready walks past
me goes to the back of the car
reads my license plate memorizes it
walks back
up slams his fist on my hood and gets in
his car
and i was like huh well that was weird
so now traffic's kind of moving a little
bit and i'm like [ __ ] this guy what
cop no no no he was he had like sandals
on and shorts he was like a hippie kind
of guy
so now i'm like well that was weird but
he's on a cell phone this is when cell
phones were like
if somebody's on a cell phone you
noticed it yeah a big brick
and i was like oh that's weird so now
we're on the main streets and i'm
following him but something's up
and then he gets to a green light stops
and i stop behind him and everybody's
like why isn't this guy going here in
the green light
there's a bar on the corner a guy runs
out of the bar
jumps in my convertible jesus christ
crazy he had a leather jacket on he was
just day drinking at some bar it was
[ __ ]
we're like you know he's in the back and
i'm trying to get
becky yeah so so i'm driving now the
the guy in the car peels off he's like
i'm out of here [ __ ] these guys but my
friend will handle this the ex-con
or whoever that guy is the guy who waits
at bars for the phone call
so bill it's for you
it's jeff i've been waiting for this
call for five years
all right this man saved my life back
and nominated
jumps in the back seat pulls packy back
there they're having a fist fight on
their knees
in the back seat just like a cartoon so
i'm just like
driving looking backwards trying to not
kill myself still driving
because we're on the street the street
is moving so
so i'm like ah i'm like trying to do
swings like back here like trying to
help [ __ ] like doing some backward
hammers you know
like trying to get this guy like a mom
discipline her children in the back seat
you guys stop it yes exactly i will turn
this car around
exactly take you back to your creepy
ball so this is a man this is a guy's
you know balding he's got a leather
jacket on with patches on it and
you know he's got a half a beard this is
a dude beating up kids
beating up a kid but that that [ __ ]
mom strength kicks in where you're just
like
scared for your life you know fight or
flight so pack he's like
windmill windmill wind in the windmill
and uh so i just scream i go packy push
him out
push him out so packy gets some kind of
demon in him and he just gets up under
the guy and goes ah
the guy goes over the back seat off the
trunk
rolls onto the street and then like cars
try not to hit him somebody runs over
his hand
and i'm like oh the guy goes
oh my god what is happening so we go to
the house party
and we're like oh my god you're not
gonna we're telling everybody i gotta
hold pow-wow around the living room i'm
like this crazy pack he pushed about it
was insane
and peggy's just sitting the corner
smoking not saying anything he was a
psycho
i think he since died but uh you should
i usually have packy with you at all
times
yeah i think he's dead now yeah there's
no way that guy's alive yeah yeah oh my
god
he got the head packing took that guy's
seat at the bar
yes yes exactly were you there for
katrina
i was an hour away but my family was
there and all my friends were there i
was at a lsu
in baton rouge that's the capital yes i
don't know why
yeah kind of like albany did you go to
lsu is that where you graduated from
well i didn't graduate from there i had
to finish online because i started
comedy
but is lsu crazy [ __ ] party school
crazy party i mean those football games
it was like the coliseum it was
unbelievable
right i got beat up a few times got
arrested uh once
great fun story tell me they wouldn't
allow booze in the car
in the the stadium you know tiger
stadium huge thousands of thousands of
people
so we would line our chest with ziploc
bags full of whiskey
okay and so we're walking in and some
cop goes
let me pat you down there you know i'm
like ah [ __ ] so me and my friend are
there
he pats down he feels the the squishy
titties he's like what's this he left
the shirt we're all lined up with
whiskey bags
and he goes all right and he grabs us
and he like puts us down on the table
they rip the whiskey off of us
and then a fight breaks out like 20 feet
away just melee fist fight so that all
the cops run over there
my friend grabs the ticket book that he
was filling out
it was like this leather-bound ticket
book that you give citations with
and so we left the game we ran around
the campus just giving people fake
tickets
it was great we're like hey you're too
hot to handle you're under arrest fatty
and we give us some lady
and it was so uh was so fun so we still
have that book that's [ __ ] great but
yeah wild times
great school great town great time
because you used to have used to be a
porker back in the day right
ah college i was okay but yeah i was
just a skinny dweeb
in college you know right but it was
just so fun you know we're like whoa hey
you know you trying to do the whistle
yeah hey skank that jet skirt's too
short you're gonna have to sit on my
face
good time we had the guy uh i should've
been sitting shouldn't
say his name but hunter brown and uh
he was the [ __ ] scariest most
fearless guy
and he would do [ __ ] that was just mean
for his sake like it was just funny to
him and no one else liked it it was like
damn that's cold-blooded but he was like
ah he's laughing in the corner
like one time he was standing by a keg
at a party and he's like you need a
refill
give me that and he would turn around
and pour it and i looked over and his
dick was in the cup
while he's filling with beer and i'm
like who does that help
you know it gives you a quick giggle but
this guy's drinking your dick juice now
and it doesn't hurt him enough really i
don't know there's no point to it except
for people is he like a tough guy too he
could be he would fight if he wanted him
to but he was uh he was just all about
mischief like he one time he was like we
gotta put this grandfather clock
in the pool and i'm like i don't know
man that's an old clock i think weighs a
thousand pounds he's like
seems to be important to somebody yeah
we're sitting on the couch drinking a
beer trying to make out with girls and
stuff and he's like all right i'll get
the skateboard
you bend it over then we'll prop it up
on the skateboard wheel right out of
here i'm like but then we have to leave
and he's like i know but it'll be great
he was that guy and now he's like the uh
the the treasurer for a big college
i don't know how they hired his ass
hunter brown does sound like the
treasurer of the college
yeah yeah we've had two threesomes
together me and hunter he's the guy who
filmed me
with the video camera when the girl sat
on my face
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah college man yeah good times
basically i was uh plowing a uh a rotund
lady and uh i couldn't get it up anymore
so i said all right just come up here
and and i'll
pleasure you while you see that i think
that's a nice thing but i had her
knees on both sides of me and i looked
over and i heard giggling my friend's
holding a vhs style camcorder
on the shoulder and he's just in the
doorway like
and then she gets up she's like what the
[ __ ] and she's chasing him and he's
filming her
while running this is all going to get
me in trouble but uh
you didn't do anything you didn't do
anything that chicks give
they degeneres yeah they really like it
so tell me the fattest
the fattest fatty you've ever fattied i
banged a gal once from the boot
this is in new orleans that was a bar in
new orleans and uh it would shut down at
like
six and i was working this pig all night
and uh finally she kind of let up and
and started dancing with me and we
started making out on the dance floor
and i could taste kielbasa
and then uh we go back to her me and i
mean a friend he
really have meat breath oh yeah oh yeah
i was pulling jimmy dean out of her
teeth
and uh my friend pulled like a like a
good
and uh he was like a hot guy who was
like well-dressed and so we go back to
his place but
we were basically like seniors in high
school so he lived with his parents
and we had to [ __ ] the gals in the same
room as each other
and he had the hot one and she's
screaming and moaning and i remember i
was like sobering up
and i had the lady on the floor and uh
you know i was on top and i kept rolling
over and i was still on top
and you know it's just i kind of wasn't
getting it up and then i
i have to hear him plowing away like a
champ and she's moaning and screaming
and
my girl's like everything okay you gotta
work up a boner to your friend
yes yes yes and she kept looking up like
i wish i was that
gal you know and it was pretty soon you
wish she was that girl too
you looked at her that was your first
guy she just giggled together he goes i
know right we both wish you were there
[Laughter]
when we did our half hour specials
together in boston half hour comedy
central specials you were [ __ ] sick
yet
would you have poisoning or something
like that h pylori yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah i remember
if you go watch mark norman's half can
we pull up mark norman's half hour
his face is like having an allergic
reaction to something because
mark is a skinny mark is [ __ ] ripped
yeah let's let's get a look at this fat
[ __ ] face look at that porker yeah so
what what's the story there because that
was because you
look at that yeah you're you're on they
tried to clean it up with some makeup
but yeah this is comedy central that
they won't let you have an inch
yeah they [ __ ] won't let you have an
inch they've well they folded and they
[ __ ] gave up
i had a pilot with them i had an
animated show i'm taking it all to
netflix
yeah yeah true tv most likely
a bit i had [ __ ] running down my leg i
mean you were [ __ ] during this
special
i was [ __ ] i they they asked if i
wanted to wear a diaper you can see my
face is so popular because
i was going to say because mark is a
he's ripped normally but the face is so
puffy there
and i'm in pain like i'm just my head is
i've got fever i'm
sweating there to keep stopping hold on
they didn't do the dab you know and then
put me back in so what so what happened
though
i uh when you eat fecal matter
you were eating ass yeah and uh i got
this
virus called h pylori and it was
terrified because it just
i was [ __ ] like butter i was pissing
foam i didn't know what was going on
and i took kissing foam i took all these
std nothing i was like i got aids it
must be aids
so eventually i go to this doctor and he
takes a blood sample whatever
and he goes uh two days later he goes
are you sitting down
and i was like oh god just give it to me
i've had it for like a week now i don't
know what it is
that wasn't getting better any day ever
it was nothing no i was getting worse
and i'm bloated as [ __ ] i have all this
tv stuff to do and i had to do it
because they don't give a [ __ ] comedy so
won't reschedule for you they don't give
you who you are
and i was nobody so the guy the doctor
was like are you sitting down i was like
yeah yeah he goes you have h
and i i just like fell out i thought
he's going to say hiv and he goes you
have h pylori and i'm like oh
he goes he's got to take one antibiotic
and you're fine you piece of [ __ ]
and then but but he's the one who told
you it's from ingesting fecal matter yes
do you remember whose ass it was uh
there were so many i think it was amy
schubert no no i don't know it's gonna
be a joke yeah that's why these queefs
on twitter
give me [ __ ] they go this sucks there's
nothing here you're a comedian you do
this for a living you come guys with
nazi
i'm like yeah yeah but give it time you
fat douche takes time you have that joke
reader
that's not hate the joke raider really
yeah
what are you tweeting [ __ ] i know i mean
look i hate the guy he's a dweeb but the
joke's on him you got to sit there and
stare at my twitter all day or get a
ping
every time i tweet like have had a
[ __ ] i don't care
do you look at his ratings i have to
because he gets it in like within four
seconds of me
sending the joke so i'm like what is
this it's called mark norman
he's got my avatar he's got my name in
there it's crazy there was at a time
there was a mark norman joe raider joke
raider
yeah that guy i liked yeah cause he was
like he would like defend you
yeah and look i'm not mad at the guy he
can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants i'm
just saying it's
it's a little annoying because you're
like i'm trying to work out here man
don't just grade me off my first
attempt yeah you know like being at the
gym and they're like you're
you're fat it's like that's why that's
why i'm here [ __ ] i'm trying to work
it out
so you tweeted i just saw a kkk member
at a wawa he
should be out of sheets great joke
thanks it only got 47 i think it
involves a kkk
uh 8.3 is the mark norman joke raider
and mark norman joke raider raider
gave that an 8.5 rate well i had a joke
today that i think is a 10.
yeah and i don't say that often and i
wonder what he gave that one
i notice he's real quiet on the killer
jokes he's he's quick to pipe up on
a mediocre but i i rarely see him
you might know the guy i might that
might
could be me it could be tucker is it
it's not i promise
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]